morning Queen Elizabeth on an industrial
scale requires a huge amount of Kit and
now a massive amount of dismantling most
flags are back at full mast although
morning will continue to be observed for
another seven days within the Royal
household and for the rest of the
country well Reality Bites with a new
government facing a mounting entree of
major problems
but before any big announcement prime
minister Liz truss is attending another
massive media moment here at the UN
General Assembly in New York where
Ukraine and the global energy crisis
dominates
she's also flying in for a first
official meeting with President Biden
although moments after landing she
conceded hopes of a post-brexit UK U.S
trade deal could be many many years away
we're not going to achieve the results
overnight it is going to take time but
with a faster growing economy we can
afford to spend on the public services
that we all rely on like the National
Health Service at the same time as
enabling people to keep more money in
their pockets while that promise sinks
in back home pressing questions over how
the country will afford the 150 billion
dollar energy bailout the government
pledged to help households avoid soaring
bills a detailed trust miss when she
announced the biggest peacetime
Financial intervention ever just hours
before Queen Elizabeth died The Soaring
Energy prices she's trying to present
herself of course as a tax cutting uh
fiscally responsible conservative but
she's about to go out and and borrow 130
billion pounds perhaps on the bond
markets very very difficult to to do it
in those circumstances particularly as
that will have to be paid for uh through
taxation in some way on Friday the new
Chancellor of the exchequer Quasi
quateng will answer some of these
questions when he delivers a mini budget
expect billions for the National Health
Service tax cuts and breaks for
businesses and a plan to lift all limits
on Bankers bonuses raising eyebrows at a
time of crippling costs
as the world starts to peel away from
the pageantry of the past 10 days
British people are now living in a new
reality a brand new king a brand new
prime minister all in the space of a few
days of each other changes not seen in
the United Kingdom since 1830 and while
many people of course welcome a return
of British politics everybody knows how
difficult the challenge is ahead really
are
MPS aren't even back at work yet but
already British Railway workers say
they're planning to strike on October
the 1st over pay and conditions other
workers from other Industries may follow
in a summer dominated for months by the
resignation of Boris Johnson and the
election of Liz truss as prime minister
opposition MP say crucial times been
wasted
weeks of frantic policy making await
Eve Barker Al Jazeera London